bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
cette ut week-end les missions d'aidé à
vous sortez et vos loisirs
au sommaire de ce numéro la sppt
yvelines organise dimanche la 7e édition
de la route des butineuses 10 km sont au
programme pour un moment convivial et
pour se sensibiliser à la protection de
la nature
le haras des bréviaires participe
dimanche à la 13ème journée nationale de
l'attelage de loisir
vous pourrez notamment voir défiler
plusieurs attelage dans les rues de la
commune et ce week-end c'est le top
départ des vacances de la zone c civile
a una directrice d'yveline tourisme nous
présentera plusieurs sites des sorties
mais on commence tout de suite avec
notre premier invité francis pons
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le responsable
des organisations sportives de l'as ptt
yvelines et ce week-end vous organisé la
7ème édition de la ronde des butineuses
je crois savoir qu'il ya des kilomètres
à parcourir ce week-end voilà ce
week-end pour ceux qui partent pas en
vacances
un petit entraînement sur 10 km autour
de l'étang de l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est une course est une marche
qu'est-ce qu'ils se rallient les deux il
y à une course pour les amateurs
vraiment de course à pied
les licenciés de la fédération française
d'athlétisme du kilomètre et il y a
également une marche loisir détente ou
sur la même distance ça s'adapte à tous
on alors on s'adapte à tout le monde
surtout au niveau de la marche il n'y a
pas de problème au niveau de la course à
pied bon fait attention parce qu'on ne
peut pas prendre un dessous de cadets
sur la compétition il ya des règles
précises de sécurité vous pouvez
préciser l'âge alors sur 10 km sont que
des cadets est au dessus les cadets ce
sont des jeunes qui sont nés je crois en
99 et 2000 dont qui ont entre 15 et 16
ans en place une séance d'entraînement
c'est chronométrait c'est chronométrie
alors la première épreuve le 10 km
course lui est vraiment chronométrés
puisqu'il fait partie du challenge des
yvelines cours seront attribue des
points pour le classement et fait partie
de l'institut tir unique tour au niveau
national donc ça c'est qu'on éviterait
la marche elle s'écoule chez nous il
n'ya pas de chronométrage ont fait de la
marche des tentes pour faire le tour des
lieux de loisirs pour prendre le plaisir
de regarder les oiseaux les
et on l'a vu sur les images certains
sont déguisés aussi c'est aussi le but
parce que cette s'amuser le but c'est de
faire du sport de se faire plaisir
éventuellement on connaît m mais avant
tout c'est de se détendre
donc il ya un concours de déguisement
autour des abeilles donc tous les ans il
ya des gens qui viennent déguisés puis
on remet un prix au meilleur déguisement
et il y a une particularité dans la cour
du 10 km que l'on maîtrise c'est la
course du haut on peut le voir des fois
sur certaines images ou un garçon et une
fille sont associés avec un lien et
doivent faire la course ensemble en
permanence
attachez difficulté c'est le petit
difficultés techniques
neos été aperçus qu'au fil des années
c'est une épreuve qui plaisait beaucoup
et on a énormément d'inscrits cette
année sur le sur le duo vous avez
beaucoup d'inscrits remet sur toutes les
catégories
alors pour ce qui est de la course à
pied chronométrie on n'est pas loin des
300 inscrits dont qui laisse plus
beaucoup de place et sur la marche on
est actuellement 80 inscrits donc il ya
encore un peu de marge
et justement si on veut s'inscrire il
faut le faire maintenant on peut le
faire jusqu'au moment du départ dimanche
aux ententes à 10 heures alors pour ceux
qui sont derrière leur clavier ils
peuvent s'inscrire encore par internet
jusqu'à ce soir 20h c'est vraiment la
limite
autrement on peut s'inscrire samedi
après midi à partir de 16h à l'entrée de
l'île de loisirs à la maison d'accueil
où je serai présent pour faire les
inscriptions et le dimanche matin sur
place devant la ligne de départ à partir
de 8 heures du matin jusqu'à 9h30 on
prend encore s'inscrire
tout à l'heure vous disais que c'est
aussi l'occasion découvrir la nature ce
que la ronde des butineuses elle porte
bien son nom vous cherchez à
sensibiliser aussi autour de la nature
et de la faune oui on essaye de
sensibiliser un petit peu les gens sur
la protection de l'environnement
donc le respect de la nature pensez aux
insectes butineurs sans lesquels on
aurait du mal à se régaler dans l'est
de neutrinos nombreux plans puisque
c'est eux qui font la pollinisation
donc on aura un apiculteur on aura des
démonstrations de ski et la protection
de l'environnement pour avait la ferme
pédagogique de lui de loisirs et pour
nous c'est important le respect de la
nature il expliqué aux gens qu'il faut
pas jeter les papiers n'importe où ou
qu'il faut pas jeter les types du gène
importe où voilà faut au bout de la
septième édition vous devez continuer à
informer les gens oui tout tout tout le
temps tout en revenir sur le métier
comme on dit il faut vous bien faire
rentrer dans l'esprit des gens qu'un mot
shoah par terre ça c'est pas bon pour la
nature
un tube de plastique des bouteilles nous
c'est un bon et cc vous sensibilisez
comme disait il ya des exposants mais
aussi peut-être des dégustations alors
il y aura peut-être un petit peu de
dégustation de miel j'ai un petit
problème un apiculteur qui devait
arriver malheureusement il pourra pas
être présent pour des raisons
personnelles mais impossible on fait la
dégustation de miel 7 cette année comme
les autres années les premiers
récompensés les trois premiers de chaque
classement auront un petit pot de miel
en souvenir donc voilà on essaye de
sensibiliser autour de ça et de leur
expliquer de discuter avec eux avant la
remise des coupes
on parle de problèmes de l'environnement
merci conséquence d'être venu en plateau
pour nous parler de la ronde des
butineuses et donc pour les intéressés
c'est dimanche 17 avril à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
le départ sera donné à 10 heures et ce
sera comme on disait la septième ronde
des butineuses
on passe à un thème du monde parce que
joffrey verbruggen joue ce week-end à la
royale factory de versailles il était
découvert dans le before du grand
journal de canal+ en 2013 et cette même
année il écrivait liberté c'est le
spectacle qui présente sur les planches
versaillaise sephora namani la rencontre
et on les écoute avant de regarder en
extrême du départ à bruxelles dans le
bistrot j'ai grandi
à bruxelles jusqu'à un petit peu la vie
d'artiste à paris voilà c'est s'aider
des croquis de personnages des
personnages qui m'ont fait rire ou qui
m'ont voilà qui m'ont interpellé quoi il
ya autant de personnages belge que deux
clubs français puisque ça démarre à
bruxelles et puis ça se passe à paris ça
me rend dingue tous ces artistes qui
volait le belge quoi alors que moi je
fais tout pour être français
je joue en france je bois du vin j'ai
une haute estime de moi il est une
expression qui m'a halluciné très tôt
c'est l'expression quand tu rencontres
une fixette est rare les mecs disent
souvent excuses et mademoiselle c'est
possible d'avoir votre 06 d'imagés cela
en belgique à bruxelles
parce que c'est mademoiselle c'est
possible d'avoir 0 472
bonjour et bienvenue chez jean-claude be
queen tu viens de belgique
j'adore la belgique
j'adore les belges vous êtes gentils
vous aimez faire là vous pouvez revoir
l'intégralité de cet entretien dans le
kiosque du mercredi 13 13 avril il est à
regarder sur notre site internet et le
dimanche 17 avril la fédération
française d'équitation et le comité
national de tourisme équestre organise
la 13e journée nationale de l'attelage
de loisir
c'est une manifestation à laquelle
participe le haras des bréviaires et
pour nous parler de cette journée marie
pierre bataille nous a rejoint en
plateau bonjour vous êtes responsable de
l'antenne région ile-de-france du haras
qu'est ce que le public va pouvoir
découvrir le dimanche alors cours de
cette journée va essentiellement
découvrir une dizaine d'attelages qui
sont des attelages qui viennent
essentiellement de l'actif c'est
l'association du cheval de trait en ile
de france et donc par là on aura une
diversité d'attelage et par les voitures
et aussi par les chevaux puisqu'on aura
plusieurs races représentées et on aura
même une 1000 l'attelage de loisir
qu est ce que c est ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer l'attelage de loisir lors
l'attelage de loisir c'est une
discipline qui permet surtout de
découvrir la nature est plus proche de
la nature est proche de l'animal voilà
et c'est surtout une pratique conviviale
puisque on peut la pratiquer en famille
ou
travelling voilà et c'est surtout aussi
une pratique qui accessible à tous dans
le sens où vous pouvez avoir de 7 à 77
ans et vous pouvez très bien monté sur
un attelage il n'y a pas de souci voilà
ça dimanche
un défilé est organisé dans les rues des
bréviaires est ce que le public va
pouvoir monter sur l'attelage et
profiter de ce défilé
alors lors de cette journée non le
public ne pourra pas monter sur les
attelages c'est vraiment pour la
diversité de la discipline par contre on
va se rattraper un mois après donc lors
de notre journée du samedi 28 mai où là
avec les journées portes ouvertes c'est
vraiment pour faire découvrir la
discipline au public
hélas les personnes pourront goûter dans
les voitures et prendre les guides voilà
en toute sécurité
je précise donc ça dimanche on pourra
admirer exode attelage de loisirs voilà
et il ya aussi des ateliers weeks alors
vu naître le matin puisque on aura un
atelier nat âge puisque en fait on
accueille des percherons et que c'est
percheron une façon particulière de
nattes et leur crinière et leur que donc
ça on le fera découvrir au public
voilà on aura aussi des ateliers
pédagogiques qui seront ouverts et
ensuite l'après midi on aura surtout
aussi des animations ludiques donc voilà
pour faire découvrir aux gens les
manières dont ont pu utiliser cette
discipline vraiment pour s'amuser
voilà ce sera en entraîner les gens
peuvent venir quand ils veulent tout à
fait donc contre lille bien sûr
donc c'est de 10h à 12h 14h 17h voilà et
en même temps vous avez le parc du haras
qui accueille en ce moment les juments
et les poulains donc en fait le les gens
pourront se promener à l'intérieur du
parc du haras
c'est aussi sensibiliser un peu le
public auprès de l'animal en lui même
oh oui c'est surtout pour les amoureux
de la nature et des chevaux et jouer
même des personnes qui aiment les
animaux en général parce qu'en général
quand on a un chien
on est adepte des choux avec vous
attendez beaucoup de monde ce week-end
et bien pour cette année en fait c'est
la première année que l'on participe à
la journée nationale de l'attelage par
contre l'année dernière quand on a fait
une 1re journée portes ouvertes on a vu
300 personnes
voilà faut que la météo soit avec nous
pour l'attelage mais en fait la seule
condition
merci marie pierre bataille bon on va
dire est que le beau temps soit grève de
ceux-là la 13ème journée nationale de
l'attelage de loisir au haras des
bréviaires c'est donc dimanche 17 avril
de 10 heures à 17 heures et vous le
disiez l'entrée est libre et on prend
maintenant la direction du pavé du canal
la librairie située à montigny le
bretonneux nous fait partager une envie
de lecture pour le week-end le coup de
coeur de stéphanie férial s'est porté
sur invisible sous la lumière de kaïs
najder docteur l'auteure canadienne
s'intéresse au destin du jeune athlète
écoutez stéphanie férial ans laurent je
te présente dernier coup de coeur
vraiment gros coup de coeur invisible
sous la lumière
c'est l'histoire de hagena tôt et déjà
avec un prénom comme ça serait plus
génial c'est une vieille dame d'un peu
plus de son temps qu'un jour un jeune
homme et sa soeur viennent prendre dans
sa vient de chercher dans sa dans sa
maison de retraite
elle comprend pas très bien ce qui se
passe tout son temps donc elle n'a pas
toute sa tête évidemment ils embarquent
dans sa boîte dans la voiture et puis
elle voit bien que la règle et les
frères nations sont toujours en train de
se chamailler et elle repère quand même
que la jeune fille pratique la course à
pied et la revoilà qui est qui se
souvient de qui elle étaye la jeune
fille qu'elle était la jeune femme
qu'elle était la femme qu'elle était et
elle qui a pratiqué énormément
énormément la course à pied donc on est
en 1920 à peu près une dizaine d'années
on est dans
il a été élevé dans une ferme à
connaître bhutto d'un milieu plutôt
modeste
elle va nous raconter avec sa fratrie
donc son père d'un premier mariage avait
déjà eu les enfants elle sa mère était
plutôt guérisseuse avec elle un médecin
mais connaissait très bien les plantes
et elle savait guérir donc beaucoup de
gens venaient venait la voir où venaient
envoyé on l'envoyait justement courir
pour aller chercher le médecin pour
aller voir le bonheur est là à la fois
l'agilité du nadia comaneci les jambes
du marais josé pérec en fait son accord
et effectivement elle va être opéré à 15
18 ans par un entraîneur pour justement
la faire pratiquer un point niveau la
course à pied et notamment pour qu'elle
a avec l'équipe canadienne pour
participer en 28 aux jo d'amsterdam où
pour la première fois des femmes vont
participer aux épreuves d'athlétisme
voilà c'est un super robot taisen voilà
et le samedi 16 avril le pavé du canal
accueil yann arthus bertrand pour une
séance de dédicace de son livre you man
tiré du film documentaire du même nom
c'est à pas à partir de 16h30
et on poursuit cette ut week-end le
magazine de vos sorties et vos loisirs
avec notre nouvel invité puisque nous
allons partir sur les deux semaines de
vacances dès le vendredi 15 avril c'est
le départ des vacances de la zone c si
villa bonjour bonjour vous êtes la
directrice des vignes tourisme et vous
avez quelques rendez vous à nous
présenter et notamment le château de
monte-cristo avec des chasses aux
trésors je crois notamment effectivement
vous allez découvrir pendant les
vacances au château de monte-cristo à
port marly il faut le préciser
des énigmes des indices des messages
plein d'épreuves pour une magnifique
chasse au trésor qui vous sera qu'il
voulait sera complètement palpitant à la
fin de la journée c'est la première
c'est le 19 avril le mardi 3 26
effectivement donc à une semaine
d'intervalle
il y a deux manifestations de ceux de ce
style et puis il ya aussi autre chose au
château de monte-cristo puisque on vous
propose d'être un apprenti comédien et
dans le cadre d'un jeu de rôle /
effectivement les histoires d'alexandre
dumas vous pourrez jouer devant les
parents et amis qui sont venus vous voir
donc
et découvrir ce métier de comédien le
bon moyen de découvrir son talent de
comédien amateur et à l'espace
rambouillet c'est pour tours là des
rapaces absolument on découvre les
rapaces à l'espace rambouillet puisque
non seulement c'est la forêt mais il ya
également un spectacle de rapaces en vol
libre
donc c'est l'occasion de découvrir des
hiboux des chouettes des faucons des
buts j'en passe et des meilleurs vous
pourrez les découvrir dans la volière et
puis participer et regarder tout ce qui
est nourrissage préparation au vol
tout ce qui est
la nécessité de commandes de traiter les
les 3l ont un mot de ce style qui sont
quand même pas si facile que ça c'est un
petit peu dangereux aussi
c'est magnifique mais c'est dangereux et
puis ça vous permettra de les approcher
parce que c'est la seule occasion on
peut approcher ce style d'animaux donc
voilà encore une visite découverte un
petit peu spécifique un peu hors du
temps finalement là on fait un peu un
grand écart on va la celle-saint-cloud
sept autour de la cuisine
voilà donc ce sont des ateliers
culinaires cuisine du monde
effectivement que l'on peut découvrir à
la celle-saint-cloud c'est du 19 au 22
avril prochain et là vous découvrirez
les cuisines italiennes antillaise
africaine asiatique un peu partout dans
le monde
vous pourrez les découvrir ensemble et
puis les goûter en famille donc c'est
vraiment le tour du monde culinaire que
l'on vous propose à la celle saint cloud
ce sont des stages ce sont des ateliers
les ateliers
là on va partir sur l'eau à lille de
loisirs des boucles de seine ce qu'il ya
des stages de voile absolument donc donc
à lille de loisirs des boucles de seine
un petit peu plus loin dans le
département vers vers le département de
l'eure finalement on vous propose
d'aller sur l'eau de perfectionner sa
voile sa conduite sur l'eau finalement
et puis ça vous permet aussi de
découvrir les petits coins et les
recoins et les plages de la de l'île de
loisirs est d'être un petit peu en
vacances il fait du soleil puisqu'on est
sur l'eau sur un bateau c'est les
vacances et de montrer nos à ses parents
si on est des enfants de montrer ce
qu'on sait faire c'est sûr mais ça c'est
tout à fait ça et pour l'avertir sera
alors pas un dernier rendez-vous mais
des dernières rendez vous et ce sont les
fermes du département qui propose des
activités un peu particulière qu'ils
font les cueillettes voilà alors nous
avons quelques fermes cueillette nous
avons la ferme dans quoi ni par exemple
la femme du jardin dans quoi ni pardon
la ferme de viltain où on fabrique aussi
du lait on a
la ferme de gally et
on a également que je le peux je
n'oublie pas qu'est ce que l'on à la
ferme des logis à jumeaux ville est bien
dans ces fermes
on peut découvrir les premières phases
c'est ce qu'on voit à l'écran
effectivement on découvre les produits
frais que l'on va pouvoir cuisiner en
rentrant à la maison
que ça soit des fruits ou des légumes
mais aussi dans ses cueillettes on peut
cueillir des fleurs pour décorer la
maison c'est vraiment l'occasion pour
lés parents de montrer aux enfants ce
que c'est que le produit frais la nature
de revenir un peu aux sources puisque
finalement c'est de ça dont on a besoin
lorsqu'on habite en ville et de se
rendre compte que l'on peut aller soi
même chercher ses légumes et ses frais
de se faire dès bon petit repas derrière
c'est ça en fait c'est ce que l'on
appelle le zéro kilomètre on consomme
les produits que l'on vient de cueillir
juste à côté de chez soi
merci civile a una de tout ces petits
rendez vous toutes les idées sorties et
bien d'autres sont à retrouver sur le
site d'yvelines tourisme on continue ce
set week-end avec une page cinéma cette
semaine bertrand pigné des yeux d'elsa
saint cyr l'école ils vous invitent à
pied de guerre écoutez le le coup de
coeur des yeux d'elsa cette semaine
c'est un festival que nous hébergeons
pour la deuxième année consécutive le
festival play it again c'est un festival
de cinéma de patrimoine les films d'hier
dans les salles d'aujourd'hui c'est le
slogan c'est un festival qui se passe
sur toute la france et les salles le
souhaitant s'associe avec des
distributeurs pour mettre en avant
certains films 15 films en l'occurrence
de leur catalogue
alors dans la zone de saint quentin il y
à là le cinéma le grenier à sel à
trappes qui participent et puis nous
aussi nos vallées cda de saint cyr
l'école pour nous notre programmation on
a choisi deux films français l'eau à la
bouche de jacques doniol valcroze film
de 59
et puis
une aussi longue absence film de henri
colpi avec alida valli henry wilson qui
avait une palme d'or en 61 mais on a
aussi choisi un troisième film qui va
nous permettre de poursuivre notre
travail de 6 des conférences autour des
films des années 80 on avait diffusé
blade runner on a diffusé ce signe de
john carpenter et là on va diffuser
encore un film emblématique des années
80 il s'agit de rambo avec sylvester
stallone un film de ted kotcheff j'aurai
le plaisir de le présenter le vendredi
15 avril
ce vendredi et puis vous en dire un peu
plus sur ce film alors évidemment il
s'agit de la grande histoire très connue
des personnages rambo le tout premier
qui est vraiment un film à re découvrir
sur grand écran on en a souvent une
image un peu galvaudé c'est un film
beaucoup plus intéressant que ce qu'il
n'y paraît play it again ça se passe
aussi attrape le samedi 16 avril à 18
heures vous pouvez redécouvrir femmes au
bord de la crise de nerfs un film
incontournable de près de pedro à hold
up almodovar sorti en 1989
je vous propose de regarder un extrait
de la bande annonce bord de la crise de
nerfs une histoire de femmes qui aiment
les arbres je n'ai jamais aimé d'autres
hommes que tout
dis moi que tu serais morte si je
n'étais pas revenu je serai partout si
tu n'étais pas revenu des femmes qui
adore se venger
et des hommes qui essaient de leur
échapper
by van on moi je sais qu'il va vous
appeler ivan s qui va de mappy et oublie
ce guignol maintenant vous voulez vous
me dire qu'ils estiment déjà faible ivan
tu said i'm your man
un dernier rendez vous cinéma à noter
l'équipe du film baby sitting 2 sera en
dédicace au cultura à plaisir le samedi
16 avril à partir de 15 heures wilfrid
riche et patrick jacques de dixmude les
avait rencontrés à la sortie du film
c'est la vraie difficulté d'un numéro 2
s'est hissé de conserver ce qui a plu
aux gens tout en essayant de changer
suffisamment de choses pour que ce soit
pas exactement pareil donc c'est pour ça
qu'on est passé de la garde d'un enfant
à la garde d'une mamie dans le numéro 2
et voilà c'est un film de fait dans
numéro 1 est une vraie comédie d
aventure dans dans le numéro deux mois
et pour les amoureux de la photographie
il y à notre concours qui est toujours
d'actualité le thème de ce mois ci c'est
l'architecturé contemporaine
alors dégainé vos objectifs il ya de
quoi faire à saint quentin en yvelines
vous pouvez envoyer vos clichés à
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran c'est
celle de la rédaction vous pouvez aussi
passer par la page facebook et vous avez
jusqu'au 6 mai nous annoncerons les
résultats le 13 mai voilà le magazine
est maintenant terminée je vous remercie
de nous avoir suivis la semaine
prochaine vous retrouverez nikkei
lindoro il vous donnera à nouveau des
idées sorties et de loisirs
en attendant je vous souhaite un
excellent week-end et de très bonnes
vacances à ceux qui peuvent en avoir